Президентські вибори в Україні мають відбутися наприкінці березня наступного року.
Основні кандидати вже розпочали активно агітувати за себе,
особливо у соцмережах.
А дехто навіть встиг порушити закон.
Олег Ляшко
Олег Ляшко пише, як допоміг спортивній школі на Чернігівщині.
І що "діти не повинні пити, курити чи ширятися,
а повинні ставити рекорди і прославляти рідну Україну".
А також, як видно з фото, на думку Ляшка, прославляти і його особисто.
У статті 31 Закону про освіту чітко сказано,
що забороняється залучати здобувачів освіти до участі в заходах,
організованих політичними партіями, крім заходів, передбачених освітньою програмою.
Агітація за Ляшка передбачена програмою цієї чернігівської школи
чи це просто безвідповідальність політика, викладачів і батьків?
Петро Порошенко
Президент Петро Порошенко також запостив себе
в День молоді в оточенні юних українців.
Але принаймні не дітей і не у футболках з його ім'ям.
Ще одна тема з нещодавніх постів Порошенка - ремонт доріг.
Президент пишається, що особисто відкрив ділянку оновленої автотраси між Запоріжжям і Дніпром.
Щоправда, ця ділянка - менше 24 кілометрів.
Юлія Тимошенко
Юлія Тимошенко розпочала агітацію за себе однією з перших.
Була навіть в образі принцеси Леї з культового фільму "Зоряні війни".
Тимошенко нагадала, що таку зачіску носили сольдадери - жінки,
які брали участь у мексиканській революції.
А також провела паралелі з ними, натякнувши, що вона теж героїчна і хоробра.
Анатолій Гриценко
Анатолій Гриценко потролив Юлію Володимирівну щодо її ідеї канцлера для України.
Пише, що це шедеврально і милозвучно, як Жозефіна Петренко.
Політик також критикує владу.
Розповідає, що робив, коли був міністром оборони
та роз'яснює, чий він проект: олігарха чи зарубіжного партнера.
Один з останніх постів - про перший кльов.
Гриценко показує, кого зловив на мастирку та кукурудзу.
Юрій Бойко
Юрій Бойко на своїй сторінці у Фейсбук постить нечасто.
Натомість регіональні осередки "Опозиційного блоку" активно цитують свого лідера
і спекулюють на темі цін, інфляції, ветеранів та релігії.